[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY CHANG: Hi, everybody.
I'm Andy Chang, Product Manager
at Google's Cloud Security
team, and I'm
joined here by Dan.
DANIEL HYMEL: I'm Dan Hymel.
I'm with Capital One and I
perform in our cloud governance
and compliance space for our
multi-cloud environments.
ANDY CHANG: And Dan and I will
be splitting the presentation
duties.
I'll do the beginning part, Dan
will talk about Capital One's
experience living this in the
cloud, and then we'll wrap up.
DANIEL HYMEL: Sure.
When I start, I'm going to
maybe ask you a question.
Heck, I'll ask
that question now.
What's in your wallet?
[LAUGHTER]
So I'll start with,
actually, a cautionary tale.
So stay tuned for that.
And you're going to see a
slide that you're probably not
used to at Google
presentations of this type.
Thank you for coming.
ANDY CHANG: Thank you, Dan.
Cool.
So you're in SEC209,
"Shared Responsibility, What
This Means for You as a CISO."
And I think, hopefully,
you're benefiting
from some of the comfiest
chairs for any of the talks,
much better than the ones
in the large stage area.
So as you've
probably-- since you've
been through a few
of these sessions,
we're also taking
questions in the Dory.
And so go to your app.
If you have questions that
come up as we're talking,
please enter those in and we'll
handle them towards the end.
We'll be covering a few things.
Overall, one of the questions
that I get talking to customers
is what is the exact split
on the shared responsibility
model?
How do I understand it?
How do I leverage it?
How do I make sure
that the cloud provider
is doing what they're
supposed to do
and that my own company is
doing what we're supposed to do?
So we're going to talk a little
bit about the perceptions
of what customers care
about in security,
the understanding that
shared responsibility
division, focusing on
visibility and control.
And then, ultimately, focusing
on a quick architecture
example.
Then I'll turn it over
to Dan to talk you
through the lived
experience at Capital One,
how they've been successful
on multiple public clouds.
And then we'll wrap up
with questions and answers.
So when customers
talk to me, the things
I hear that folks
care about are really
that the right data is
delivered to the right customer
at the right point in time
for the right purpose each
and every time.
And that's some of
the core of security.
The right thing and
only the right thing
happens when it's
supposed to happen.
In addition, given as we all see
the current threat environment
and the activity of
threat actors increasing,
it's important not just to
react to [AUDIO OUT] situations,
but also to be able to
anticipate and innovate ahead
of some of these threats.
In addition, many of you are
in regulated environments,
so it's important
[AUDIO OUT] partner
to be able to essentially
enable you to deliver
on your responsibilities
while running your businesses
in the public cloud.
And lastly, and really
the focus of this,
is understanding and having
a clear understanding
of responsibility model.
I think we're going to
switch over to [AUDIO OUT]..
OK.
So now we're-- [AUDIO OUT].
I think this is [AUDIO OUT].
SPEAKER 1: Sorry, folks.
Give us one second to get
this straightened out.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
ANDY CHANG: OK.
All right, so this is better.
Cool.
All right, so we're
going to talk about-- oh,
I think it's still
cutting in and out.
Technical difficulties.
Cool.
All right, can you
guys hear me OK?
All right, we're going
to go with the hand mic
and see how this goes.
Thank you.
So we're going to-- the
focus of this talk is really
on the understanding.
Enabling you guys
to understand where
that split is from a shared
responsibility standpoint.
And really, ultimately,
for you as CISOs,
you as folks part
of the security part
of your organization, enabling
you to actually accelerate
your company's business velocity
with enabling your stakeholders
to have and
understand really what
is the controllable and
acceptable amount of risk.
So really focusing on this area.
At Google, the way we think
about the shared responsibility
model is really around two key
items, security of the cloud
and security in the cloud.
And we'll talk about how
we divvy those things up
in a moment.
From a core principle
standpoint, security at Google
is done defense in depth.
We have at least two layers
of protections that are
independent from each other
between anything of interest--
anything you want to protect
and any kind of bad activity
or threat actor--
at scale.
So, as you can imagine, Google--
I think other folks
have said we're
25% plus of the internet
from a traffic standpoint.
Things done at Google for
security or for other things
have to be done fully
at scale and work
at scale, and by default. How
do we enable our developers, how
do we enable the system
so that the controls that
are necessary and required
are enabled by default so
that folks can run?
At the core underlying
this is really
the use of strong cryptographic
credentials and identity.
And what that means
is that whether it's
a machine, whether it's
a human, whether it's
the data, whether it's
the code, whether it's
the underlying
service, they all have
unique cryptographic
identities that we
can compare against what
should be happening.
And provenance, the ability to
establish, through a hardware
root of trust, that the
underlying hardware,
the low-level software, the OS
software, the applications that
are running are all fully
attested to at each stage
and that we're running the
right code at the right time.
The other part of this
is that, at Google, we
think trust isn't gained just
through technology, but also
through transparency.
And really, what that means to
you and to customers in general
is thinking about reducing what
we call the unverifiable trust
surface.
What that means is minimizing
the amount you actually
have to trust us as
a cloud provider.
Having you being provided
enough information so
you can make a
decision of your own
to verify the claims
that we're making.
And that's a core part of
what we're trying to do.
Ultimately, we're interested
in providing customers
the capabilities to help you
build secure applications
and fulfill your part of the
shared responsibility model.
When we think about the
controls that are in place,
we really think about
them in three areas.
Underlying control,
things that really
help you protect the data;
visibility, the ability
to classify the data and monitor
the actions on that data;
and then detection
response, the ability
to actually validate
the controls running
and detect essentially things
that are non-compliant,
activities that could be
threats, or from bad actors.
And for each of these
areas, we have technology
that we provide to enable that.
When we think about the
shared responsibility model,
it's important to understand
that the boundaries
of that shared
responsibility vary
based on which types of
services you're using.
And for many of our
customers, they're
using a spectrum
of services, which
is why it's not
surprising that, as a CISO
or as part of the security team,
the details for what service
and which part can add
to additional complexity.
And so it's important
to understand
where those divisions are.
When you're running on premise--
everything in the blue
represents the customer.
So when you're
running on premise,
you own all of your
hardware stack,
your relationships, the
underlying software running.
So not surprisingly,
the full responsibility
is really on you
as the customer.
When you're running as an
infrastructure as a service,
which is essentially running
your own virtual machines
on our platform, but
installing your own images,
setting up your own
network architectures,
the responsibility for us is
to provide you the ability
to log and audit the things
that are running on the system--
the network, the underlying
hardware and infrastructure,
the pieces that you're
building on top of.
So the services we
provide to you are secure,
and then you're responsible for
putting those things together
in secure architectures.
When you're running a
platform as a service--
like BigQuery or App Engine,
one of those things--
now, really, you're providing
as code that you're running.
And we're responsible for
delivering the underlying
services that execute that
code in a safe and secure way.
And when you're using
software that we've provided,
now we're responsible,
as well, for the code.
So, if you're using
Gmail or Drive or Docs,
that code has then become
part of our responsibility.
And then the thing
that you focus on
is access to those
applications, access to the data
that you provide,
and then the data
that you're loading
into those applications.
That's a quick summary
of the different levels,
and we'll go into some
of this in more detail.
So, as we talked about
from a Google perspective,
we think about security of
the cloud and in the cloud.
Of the cloud is about
the core infrastructure
that you're then
using, and the core
services to build your
products and applications
for your consumers.
For Google, we're responsible
for security of the cloud,
and we think about it as, again,
defense, in depth, at scale,
by default. We model the
underlying architecture
that you're running on
top of in nine layers.
Everything from the
hardware all the way
through the underlying low-level
software, the applications,
and ultimately to usage.
And everything that
we do at Google
is rooted in a hardware root
of trust, which is the Titan
chip that you've heard of
through the last couple
of Next conferences.
It's a purpose-built
chip that we've built
and it sits on our compute
cards, our processor cards.
And establishes, on boot,
a cryptographic identity
for that piece of
hardware and verifies
that all the underlying
pieces of software
that are meant to boot are
doing so in the right way,
that the hardware
components are correct
and configured the right way.
And, if any of
those things fail,
that card or that
compute instance
does not actually boot and
be entered into the fleet.
And that allows us to
make sure, once something
goes through that, that
it's in a known good state
and it can be put into
the rest of the fleet
and start serving customers.
That becomes the
underlying piece
that drives our servers,
our storage, our network,
and then ultimately
our data centers.
And what that allows
us to do, then,
is reduce the threat
for folks injecting
either malicious hardware
or malicious software
into our systems.
In combination with that, as we
talked about in the beginning,
it's important for
us at Google that we
have the ability for
the code that we write
to define that the
right identity accesses
the right machine, is authorized
by the right code accessing
the right data, and it's in
the right time and context.
And that's done through
cryptographically secure
identities.
So not only users
have identities.
Machines and services
have identities,
devices have
identities, and then
code and data have identities.
And checking all of those things
when we run a Google service
is a core part of our
underlying platform.
Here's a stack with
a little more detail
of the different
pieces within Google
that come into play
to secure each layer.
You'll see that there's at least
two items at each layer that
are put together to provide
redundancy and really defense
in depth.
Whether it's the purpose-built
underlying infrastructure
or the fact that we,
from a boot standpoint,
cryptographically sign all the
pieces of our boot software,
from an operating system
and hypervisor standpoint,
we use our own version of
KVM where we stripped out
a lot of parts of
the virtual machine
monitor, reduced its attack
surface and its risk surface.
We've also then added
sandboxing in so that further
creates a level of isolation.
From an OS standpoint, we
use our own curated operating
system for our host side.
We also make that available
as the container-optimized OS
for you, as a customer, to use.
If you're using our
container-optimized OS,
you can also enable
automatic updates,
which will patch the
container-optimized OS so you
can leverage and benefit from
the same type of security
controls we run
on our host side.
From a storage and
network standpoint,
unique to cloud providers,
all services, all data,
is encrypted at rest and
in transit at Google.
The logging of both internal
Googler access, as well as
providing audit logs for
your users and your systems
and what they do
in your systems.
An identity access
management system
that allows us to do
fine-grain permissions,
and then really
managing those keys
that are core part of
encryption at scale.
From a networking side, we
have one of the world's largest
private networks.
What that means is that from
when your data or your service
is touched by a customer
from outside our network,
it basically travels wholly
on Google-owned private
networking, private fiber,
to the server in our systems.
And that gives you not only
performance advantages,
but gives you a single threat
to choke from a network security
standpoint.
There are no additional
actors in the underlying hops.
From an application standpoint,
both from the whole software
lifecycle, from static analysis
to the patching and checking
of the packages that are loaded
in, we have control over that.
We also cryptographically
sign each piece of software
as it goes through
the development stage,
and then check before it's
deployed that the manifest has
all the right policies applied.
That's something
we've externalized
to customers as a part
of binary authorization.
So, if you want to adopt
that same model that you
can run vulnerability
checks, various types
of patching checks, static
code analysis, and then
as long as code passes that
created cryptographic signature
and have that checked
before the code is deployed,
you're able to do that through
our binary authorization
product.
Once the applications
are up and running,
they're protected by
our own global front
end and the WAF capabilities and
DDoS capabilities around that.
And then we provide, as well,
our own security scanning
for L7 web application
vulnerabilities
that we use inside of Google as
a product called Cloud Security
Scanner for you to
use as a customer.
When things are
deployed at scale,
we're very fond of saying that
your first users are typically
abusers.
So whenever we deploy a service,
we see a lot of attack traffic.
Therefore, the built-in
DDoS for our own services,
the ability to be our own CA.
So it's very hard for folks
to forge anything related
to connecting to Google.
And that all services provided
at Google are at full TLS.
Finally, from an
operations standpoint,
not just trusting us,
but having third parties
do compliance checking.
The ability to do
live migration, which
enables us to do patching
of live running VMs
without taking your
services down, allows us to,
on a continuous
basis, do that level
of patching and keeping
things up to the highest
level of security.
Then we have full SOC threat
analysis and the ability,
from a user standpoint,
to connect to our services
through beyond corporate
digital trust type network,
as well as for them to do
hardware-based second factor
for security key.
And that is the structure for
every service created at Google
and used at Google.
And the tools in
which you would then
build on top of when you
use one of our services.
When we think about
enabling customers,
we do this providing
the same type
of services either in the
dark green as products
you can consume, in the light
green as either products
that you can use from Google or
that you can get from partners,
or in the case of the dark
blue, core things we still
do by default for you when
you're running on Google Cloud
Platform.
We're going to
talk and highlight
some of the key differentiators
on Google Cloud Platform that
will help you do your
job better and fulfill
your part of the
shared responsibility
from a visibility
and control side.
So one of the core
things which we announced
to general availability
this morning
is the Cloud Security
Command Center.
That's that central
pane of glass
that you can bring in detections
from Google native products,
third-party products, or
ones you've written yourself
for vulnerabilities and
threats all in one place,
and see those in
context with your assets
and the business context
of those services
and the sensitivity of the data.
Gives you one place to look for
visibility, one thing for you
to then query, understand your
data, and then the ability
to trigger prevention,
detection, and action.
In addition, what we feel is
a key part of understanding
the attack surface
is understanding
where your data is and what
sensitivity level [INAUDIBLE]..
What we provide is the same
service we used within Google
for data classification,
our cloud DLP API, which
is designed to work at data at
exabyte and petabyte scales,
which allows you then
to, number one, for data
sitting in Google Cloud Storage
or data sitting in Bigtable--
BigQuery tables-- to
classify, at scale,
sensitive data either through
our built-in classifiers,
the ability to use
regular expressions,
or to express this
in terms of data
sets that we can
train our models on.
Once you've
identified that data,
you then have the choice of
multiple de-identification
options.
Simple things like
substitution encryption,
more intricate things like
format preserving encryption,
or transformations that
allow the data still
to be usable in analytics, but
still parallel serve privacy.
In addition, unique to Google is
we provide Access Transparency,
which means that we
provide you, in our audit
logs, a notice every time a
Googler accesses your data
and for what reason.
What region that
Googler was from
and the case number, in the case
of customer-initiated support
events that triggered
that access.
This is across a wide
range of Google services,
and unlike some of the other
providers, not just restricted
to a small set of the
provided services.
Also, at Next, we're
very excited to announce
access approvals, which now
allows you to prevent Googlers
from accessing data in real
time for a subset of the data.
So not only will we notify
you if a Googler is trying
to access data, you can
actually get the ability
to say you will not allow
that and grant that access,
and the Googler will no longer
have access to that data
and will not start having
access to that data.
The results of these are
surfaced in the Cloud Security
Command Center.
Also through the
audit logging APIs.
One of the key parts
we talked about earlier
was trust through transparency.
And so part of that is
there's a lot of things
that we've told you
about our technology
and how we do things.
But you don't have
to just trust us.
We go through, twice a year,
a set of certifications.
You'll see some of these here.
And those certifications
go on an ongoing basis.
Working with your sales teams
and with your account teams,
you can get access to some of
the reports of these things.
So you can see for
yourself, whether it's
overall global standards or
country-specific standards,
how we do against
the requirements
and certifications you need
to run your businesses.
When we move to control, one
of the key things that's unique
to Google is an emphasis on
providing out-of-the-box,
top-down, logically central, but
globally distributed controls.
We were the first of
the cloud providers
to provide organization level
viewpoint, a top-down resource
hierarchy that also
is an IAM boundary
and also is a network boundary
so that you have the ability
to start your systems and
your developers in a safe mode
where they have, by
design, restricted access
that you then can
explicitly only
grant through the IAM roles.
From an IAM standpoint, we have
over 300 curated roles so out
of the box, the
separation of duties
are built in by those
products requiring explicitly
grants for folks to use that.
We have hierarchy
and inheritance
in our resource hierarchy.
So if you're given
something at a folder level,
that person then can have
the underlying roles in each
of the projects below that.
But if you're at
a project level,
you can't go up the chain
unless you're explicitly
granted that type of access.
In addition, we
have org policies
that you can define
at the top level that
can be enforced across
all your organization,
regardless of the
underlying pieces.
And then we're going to talk
about two other things that
affect your
communication pattern.
VPC Service Controls,
which provide you
the ability to define
service perimeters.
So unlike the traditional
L3, L4 networks,
which are based
on routes and IPs,
and restrictions based on IPs,
as you move to microservices,
services then have
unique identities
and you have the ability
to block services access
to particular types of
sensitive data or projects.
And those can be applied
to Google services
as well so that you can block,
for example, Google Cloud
Storage rights or reads from
a particular set of resources
only unless those
services either belong
to a particular access level
or have a particular set
of permission groups.
In addition, we also
provide a similar set
of capabilities around your
L3, L4 level networking.
So we have the ability
for you to create
what's called a shared VPC
and, in that shared VPC,
define all the
firewall rules that
apply to all the tenant VPCs.
So you have, again,
one logical choke point
where you can provide
the administration
of your overall network,
separate and independent
from the underlying
administrators
of the underlying projects.
Both of these
concepts are designed
to provide you
logical bottlenecks
and choke points for
control, but not cost you
anything on the performance
side because they're implemented
in globally distributed ways.
And those are unique to Google.
VPC Service Controls,
as I talked about,
is really defining
service-level perimeters, which
allow you to put that
around specific sets
of sensitive data, allow
you to define access levels.
And those access
levels allow you
to put policy
requirements, for example,
of what kind of geographies that
the data can be accessed from,
what kind of restricted
IPs, what potential device
characteristics are needed
to access that data.
Those access context
levels apply not only
to infrastructure
controls like this,
but also back into your G
Suite access to Docs and Gmail.
So in one construct,
access levels,
you can define a set
of controls that apply
across both G Suite and GCP.
Similarly, from a key
management standpoint,
as I talked about,
by default, your data
is encrypted at
rest and in transit.
But we know for some
of our customers,
they have additional either
regular requirements or views
of their threat
model or risk that
require greater
control of their keys,
so we provide a full spectrum.
From the left,
default encryption,
you don't have to do anything.
Your data is encrypted at rest.
Cloud key management
system, which
allows you full control
of creation of keys,
destruction of keys,
rotation, times, and periods.
Full logging.
IAM roles on those keys
so you can demonstrate
to your regulators
and auditors that you
have full control of the keys.
Cloud HSM, which is a
hardware-backed solution
so that you can have a root
of trust for those KMS keys
be in hardware.
And it's a Phipps Level 3
hardware, globally distributed
Cloud HCM system.
You can also, if you need
to have the root keys
be sourced within
your own org, you
can use cloud's essentially
customer-supplied encryption
keys, which allows you to push
the encryption keys to us when
you need something decrypted.
We do not store that key.
It stays only in memory
for the live operation
and, therefore, you
have not only the root
of trust in your
own hardware system,
we have no access to
those underlying keys.
You can also have, essentially,
the ability to stack
your own HSMs in our Colos if
you want that further level,
additional control on
essentially customer-supplied
encryption keys.
So depending on the risk
parameters of your business,
you have a full
spectrum of capabilities
available to support
data encryption.
And before I turn
it over to Dan,
I'm going to talk through now
how the various controls get
put together when you think
about a secure architecture.
So first, most customers
start with a clean slate.
They have an existing on premise
or other cloud installation.
They have identities set up,
typically not a Google identity
out of the box, from an
enterprise standpoint,
local compute,
gateways, and then data.
So the first thing to do
is to essentially connect
to cloud identity, which lets us
federate your existing identity
service.
And now brings those
identities to be
used in Google Cloud Platform.
Then, through the groups and
the underlying individuals,
assign out the IAM
roles and policies
which you want so that folks
have the correct separation
of duties.
The ability to establish
upfront org-level policies
that apply, regardless
of the underlying pieces,
across your whole organization.
For example, that VMs cannot
have publicly-facing internet
addresses.
Then the ability
to define, again,
from a L3, L4 level, and
overall control of your firewall
rules and networking
through shared VPCs.
Breaking out from an HA
standpoint and a disaster
recovery standpoint, the
various regional pieces
that you want to allocate within
each of the regions, the zones,
the resource allocation, and
then the underlying subnet
connections.
By default, and
unique to Google,
our networks are global.
So you're able to make
those connections very
straightforward.
You don't have to pair
between the different regions.
Our VPCs are global by
nature, and you're able to,
therefore, set up HA and DR
in a very straightforward way.
Next thing you want
to do ultimately
is you have data
sitting near on prem,
and you want to bring
it securely into GCP
or take the data that we compute
and bring it back to your
on prem.
So combining Cloud
Router, firewall rules,
dedicated secure interconnect,
either through our own peering
or through partner
peering, allows
you to bring the data in and
out of your area securely.
Also, we have VPNs to allow
you to do that as well.
Next piece, then, is from
an application standpoint.
Protect your application
once you serve it
from the typical
attacks like DDoS.
So you can either
use our default
global load balancer,
which as long as you
put that in front of one
of your GCE services,
will take advantage of
our global front end.
You can use one of our
managed services, which
has DDoS built in, or you
can use the Cloud Armor
product, which gives you
additional availability
and the ability to write
your own rules to fine-grain
manage your DDoS and WAF.
Next piece, then, is you
want to turn on logging
so that you have the monitoring
and evidence of things
that might happen to
allow us to do detections.
And audit logs are
turned on by default.
You can then also look at
VPC Flow Logs, firewall logs,
and then general logging.
Then you want to turn on
the monitoring, learning,
and detection pieces, which
include the Cloud Security
Command Center, security
health analytics, the ability
to look at stackdriver
monitoring,
running security scanner
on your, essentially, web
applications.
And then if you want to
dump the data into BigQuery
for additional processing.
You then create a
service project,
which allows you
to kind of create
that boundary of control for
the services you want to run.
And then create kind of a secure
perimeter using VP service
controls around that so that you
can restrict which services can
access that underlying data.
And then, ultimately, bring
those data back into GCP
through either private access,
Cloud DNS, and cloud natting.
So you can either place
your subnets into GCP
or push our subnet pieces out.
So, in summary,
those are the steps
that you take to pull things
in and are the building
blocks of you building
a secure service on GCP,
and some of the
pieces we give you
to fulfill your part of the
shared responsibility model.
So with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Dan to talk to you about
Capital One's journey.
DANIEL HYMEL: Great.
Thank you.
Are we using this mic?
ANDY CHANG: No, we can
use your mic for this.
DANIEL HYMEL: OK, great.
Andy, thank you for
opening the stage
and allowing me to
present and open
the windows on what's actually
going on inside of Capital One.
So I promised you
a cautionary tale.
And this little
creature's name is Altria.
Altria is a rescue dog that my
12-year-old daughter picked up
from the Richmond Animal
League in Richmond, Virginia.
What does this dog
have anything to do
with the topic of shared
responsibilities, compliance,
and controls?
On the cover, probably
absolutely nothing.
But take a closer look.
Take a look at what's
around her neck.
So here's the tale.
It happened shortly
after Google '18.
About a week after Google
'18, this little dog, Altria--
love her to death.
She has no malicious
intent whatsoever.
But she's a runner.
She was trained
as a hunting dog.
She's an American hound.
So on one particular night, this
was probably after the fifth
escape from the homestead--
we live on a parcel out
in the country--
we kept talking
about, let's put it
in a security fence,
an invisible fence.
And we kept holding off
because the price was too high.
So on one particular event,
she left around 8:00 PM.
She has free run of
the neighborhood.
We live in this river
canyon on the James River,
where about a mile on either
side, there are no fences.
And you can run from
the Chesapeake Bay
all the way to the mountains.
On this particular day, it
was about 11:00 PM at night.
We were exhausted.
We couldn't find her.
We came home.
And as I was planning
to go around the house
to check things out, I felt
this immense pain in my leg
and I jumped and wondered
what the heck happened.
So I looked down and on
the corner of the eye,
there was a copperhead snake.
Unfortunately, that snake took
advantage of the opportunity.
And as you know, later that day,
I was in the paramedics box.
I was at the hospital.
I was being treated for
a copperhead snake bite.
So as you know,
in everyday life,
there are risk
scenarios everywhere.
This is a very good example.
Had we actually put
in the security fence,
we would've avoided
Altria from escaping
from our private domain
out into the public.
So as a result, we
implemented this control.
It's a shock caller.
So as you approach
the fence, she
gets a really
enlightening experience.
If she's able to go beyond that
barrier into the public domain,
there are some other controls
that we've implemented.
So what you might not
know about the rescue
dogs is that when
you receive them,
you receive them with a chip.
So if they are
captured in public,
there is a way to
identify those.
We also added a collar or a tag.
The tag used to have only
our home phone number,
but she runs so much
that we actually
had to put a cell phone number
because we would get phone
calls at home when we're
actually out in the field
looking for her.
So, as you see now, it has a
lot to do with cloud controls--
I'm sorry-- with controls,
with shared responsibilities.
It's the whole community.
So let me take you into
the Capital One journey.
I'm going to open the
window for you for a moment.
You won't see this often.
And I'm going to tell
you and share with you
a few nuggets on how
we made our journey
into the cloud successful.
So Capital One, today, has
a significant need for cloud
because it enables us to
operate with the speed
and agility required to
succeed in the digital age.
Our agile sprint teams
work in two-week cycles,
and according to
them, infrastructure
must not be an impediment.
As a result of moving to the
cloud, there are some stats,
and these are real numbers.
We've moved from a
development environment
build time of three
months down to 30 minutes.
New product features
which used to take a month
now take two days.
With unparalleled visibility
into our environments,
we have an overall
improved security posture.
I'm going to talk back on
security in just a moment.
Our current cloud
status is this.
We have over 8,000 production
applications and services.
6,000 additional
services and applications
are in non-production.
And nearly 100%
of our production
in development and test
servers are in the cloud.
Additionally,
moving to the cloud
has increased our ability
to secure and manage
massive volumes of
high-quality data,
operating at a higher speed
with greater resiliency, faster
recovery, and at an
extraordinarily lower cost.
With Cloud, our
technology organization
is free to do what we do best,
build digital breakthrough
experiences for our customer.
If you are a customer
of Capital One,
feel comfortable in knowing
that we have your back
and we are doing our very
best using state of the art
technologies and best practices
to protect your sensitive data.
To make this happen, to make
this security posture happen,
we've implemented a methodology
around controls and compliance.
A lot of organizations might
call this cloud governance
or a governance function.
So essentially,
that's what it is.
It's an enterprise
function at Capital One
that balances the
need of compliance
of cloud controls,
objectives, and the needs
of various stakeholders,
from our board of directors
to executive management, to
the enterprise communities,
like operations, engineering,
info security, and cyber--
all of the communities
that come together to help
enable our security
capabilities in the cloud.
And most importantly,
our divisional customers.
These are our
lines of business--
our banking community, our
auto finance community,
our card community.
These are the application
builders and consumers
of cloud services.
Another way to look at
cloud control and compliance
is it's the totality set
of policies and procedures
that help an enterprise
move towards its goals
while minimizing
risk and conflicts.
So for us, our journey here,
our goal is all in on the cloud,
and that's just
about where we are.
So let's go back to, then,
what is this cloud compliance
function?
What I'm going to share with
you is a best practice example
that is aligned very closely
with the Cloud Security
Alliance methodology.
So think of this as
a box of cake mix,
where you flip that
box on the backside
and it gives you
all the ingredients.
These are all the ingredients
to make it happen.
These are the best practices.
You have to include all
of these, in my opinion,
in your program for
cloud compliance
to have the maximum benefit
to ensure that you're
doing the appropriate
level of due diligence
for your environment.
I'll go by these one
by one, and then I'll
give you some more detail
on what they actually mean.
So first off, you must
document and maintain
a catalog of control objectives.
These objectives are partially
derived from Nest 800-53,
or FedRAMP Moderate.
They are also a
compilation or a derivative
of your internal security
policies and procedures.
Secondly, for every
single service
that our cloud
providers offer, we
perform a security
control assessment
using a selected set
of security control
objectives in that catalog.
And, for now, our current
status for our catalog
of about 300 control
objectives, we use about 50
of those that are directly
applicable to cloud
as it relates to our
shared responsibilities.
And, of those 50, 15 of
the control objectives
are mandatory
requirements, meaning that,
if the service provider--
Google-- provides
a service to us
and it doesn't meet any of
the 15, that's a showstopper.
So we'll just tell Google,
we're not ready yet.
We need some more features
before it's safe for us
to consume that service.
Next, once you've done
the security assessments,
you move into the phase of
performing the risk analysis
on the gaps that you've
identified relative
to your control objectives.
So depending on which
industry that you're in,
you may have a different
set of objectives
than what Capital One has as
a financial service provider.
Today, we're using a composition
of qualitative and quantitative
methodologies.
We're looking very closely at
probabilistic risk analysis,
which means that there is
a probability in a risk
scenario of an event happening
over an annualized time
period causing a loss of
money in a particular range.
So now that you've
identified your gaps,
now comes the tough part.
This is a continuous process
on risk management, control
implementation, control
compliance, control exception
processing.
You have to implement
your controls.
You have to monitor your
controls for compliance.
And you have to allow
application owners
to make exceptions against using
the services that might not
have all the controls
or for which you're not
able to meet all of those.
Not a requirement,
but the next one
is the divisional
governance advisor.
And what we've done
is we've assigned
a technical subject
matter expert like myself
to support a particular line
of business that translates
everything that we've
talked about into terms
that they consume.
And most importantly,
as well, training.
The associates that
perform in this function
need to have background
as a subject matter
expert in the cloud
provided environment.
Back to shared responsibilities
component of this.
Andy talked ad nauseam about
this-- this is really great--
so I won't go into
any detail here.
But I wanted to share with you
that we understand this well,
and I'll just move on
to the next one, which
is a payout slide.
This slide basically
says, for Capital One,
we look at shared
responsibilities
from both a platform perspective
and an application perspective.
Let's take the application
perspective first.
I'm sorry, the
platform perspective.
So my team working
in cloud governance,
we do everything that
we talked about before.
We assess the services.
We ensure that they meet
our security requirements.
We work with cloud
engineering teams
and we provision the
services and make
those available to our
consumers that leverage
those services by
way of applications.
So we're accountable
for then assuring
that we implement platform
identity and access
management, that we
deploy the operating
systems appropriately, meaning
that we provision system
images.
Rather than using the
cloud provider images,
we provision our own so
that we appropriately
harden them to meet
our internal standards.
We're accountable for what
we put into the cloud,
so we take full
responsibility for that.
One particular example of
a control related to this
is a notion of rehydration.
So, as a virtual machine ages,
it takes on vulnerabilities
because the vulnerability
aging process,
and so we have a requirement
to rehydrate every 60 days.
If you go beyond that,
bells and whistles go off.
If you go past 90,
bigger whistles go off.
If you go to 120, the
canons go off and so forth.
So I think you get that.
So our cloud
governance function,
from a centralized
perspective, is
we make controls and scripts
available that either we
can run on behalf of the
development community,
or that we can give it to them
and they can actually run it.
For example, there
might be a requirement
to apply labels or tags
to all of your resources.
If the development community
forgets to do that,
they can run a
script to make sure
that they're compliant to that.
Let's move on then
to the application.
If you build it, you own it.
That's the mantra
at Capital One.
So if we offer a service
to you, you're golden.
You can use that.
It's been whitelisted.
The controls are in place, but
you have some accountability.
I'll talk a bit more
about that accountability.
So why are cloud
controls important?
I wanted to make sure that you
had full visibility to that.
For Capital One,
it's our mission
and our fiduciary
responsibility.
If you take a standard document
classification or information
handling matrix,
you will find that
your proprietary or
confidential data is probably
your most important asset and
requires a level of protection
beyond those that are
company or public.
So what we do and
how we've bifurcated
this is we look at the controls
in the cloud control catalog
in three particular areas.
There's technical,
operational, and management.
And I'll show you, on the next
slide, how we codify those.
But most importantly, the
controls have to always be on.
The windows have to
always be locked.
So that means
security protocols,
public accessibility, data
encryption, identity access,
and PCI.
There is no opportunity.
There is no tolerance
for control being off.
So where do cloud
controls originate?
I mentioned to you a
bit earlier that they
might originate from
cybersecurity frameworks, Nest,
FedRAMP, and so forth.
Here's a particular small matrix
of the 14 control categories
in the Nest
framework, where I've
bifurcated those by technical,
operational, and management.
So we take our Cloud
Control catalogs.
We look at a service
that Google has provided.
We perform that
security assessment.
The diagram below, or the
colorful green, red, blue
chart, is the actual
detail of the questions
that we might ask.
And, incidentally, I
have to say that Google
has been an extraordinary
partner in this.
Google has our scripts.
They know what we require.
They know when a service
is ready to meet the higher
bar for financial
services industry,
and so they are embracing that.
They're working very diligently
to say, hey, Capital One,
we've got this new service.
And they know what
our requirements are.
So they know when to
actually make the ask.
And finally, we complete
the service assessment.
We deliver the package.
Now, it's important to
note here, under Item C,
that it's a
cross-functional team.
We include governance, we
include engineering resources,
cyber resources, architecture,
IAM architecture and, also,
our information assurance
third-party management
function, where
we fully validate.
We have an auditable
trail that our regulators
and our internal auditors
can go back and say,
did you ask that question?
Google tells a lot of good
things about their services,
but we firmly believe
in trust, but verify.
So this is the final slide.
I've got about 15
seconds or so, and then
we'll save time for Q&A.
But here's the payout,
and this is what
resonates with shared
responsibilities from an
application owner perspective.
Here's what it means.
If you have an application--
let's take a basic, multi-tier
architecture application--
where you're going to
need a load balancer,
a web server, application
server, database and file
storage, that application
or the type of application
may require that you adhere
to an enterprise architecture
standard.
There may be a defined
architecture already.
The architecture might
even say, in order
to meet the requirements
for the architecture,
there are certain
cloud services that you
are mandated to follow.
So the application owner
defines the application.
They choose the architecture.
They select the cloud
services that are approved.
This is by no
means the only list
of what's approved
at Capital One,
so we could put dot dot dot.
After you select the
approved services,
then you become more
aware of an application
owner of what your actual
requirements for controls are.
So if you pick a Compute
Engine, if you pick Storage,
you will have some requirements
for identity access, data
encryption, and so forth.
So this is really
the whole story.
There's so much detail here.
Feel free to reach
out to me on LinkedIn
if you have some
follow-up questions.
And we'll actually go back to
Andy to close it out for us.
ANDY CHANG: Thank you, Dan.
So in summary, though
one last slide.
[APPLAUSE]
So security of the
cloud is something
the cloud provider secures.
Security in the
cloud is something
that the cloud customer
secures for their data
and their content.
At Google Cloud, we look to
empower you as a customer
with the visibility to
control and secure the things
that you're responsible for.
And as Dan talked
about, customers
can be successful in cloud
using a very thoughtful process,
structure, and clean
separations of responsibility
within their own org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]